[Music]
through our entire experience at marvel
we always try to make very disruptive
choices with each film at the end of
Winter Soldier
the guys are the bad guys we flip
everything on its head Civil War we
divorce the Avengers when we were
working on the script for an infinity
war we knew we want to make a strong
narrative choice there's an adage where
you write yourself into a corner and you
try to figure out how to get out and it
usually creates really dramatic moments
for the audience there's no bigger way
to write ourselves in a corner than
killing half the characters this is no
place today visualization was purely
just we thought about the elemental
aspect of your body and what happens to
it and that's accelerating the
decomposing process as far as who went
to dust everything's always built upon
the story and we'll just say that
there's a reason that the original six
Avengers are loved it was all story
driven it was who was where and which
character dynamics we wanted to exploit
we knew that we wanted strange and Tony
together because I wanted to see the two
egotistical characters going at each
other we knew we wanted Peter with Tony
Lord unicity you should not be here I
was gonna go home I'd when he let mr.
Tony Stark in Peter Parker developed a
father-son relationship over the course
of two films so we felt like that would
be hard to watch and it was hard to
watch on set and it was hard to watch
for the audience I think
hardik telling stories is learning
empathy I don't know people can
empathize with Danis but they can't
empathize with star-lord the love of his
life was murdered and he made a very
emotional choice that's the human choice
that you would make in those
circumstances
all of these characters make flood
choices is that a journey of revenge
after suffering this horrible opening
scene defeats where Thanos kills his
brother and Heimdall and wipes out men
it was people
how does he stopped a knows if Thor had
not been so angry and so revenge driven
he may have killed fan OHS faster and he
did Gandhi would have gone for the head
exactly but he wanted revenge she wanted
to see him Thanos his eyes as he was
killing him that gave Thanos a window to
reverse things on all these characters
have emotional vulnerabilities that
complicate their ability to do what
needs to be done makes them interesting
to watch if all they did was make the
right choice of which is a fairly
predictable and boring story after a
while we anticipated the ending being
complicated for people because it was
complicated for ourselves but we didn't
anticipate the depth of emotion that
people would experience from that ending
Ruffalo is in a theater in New York and
he was in a cap and glasses he was there
with his son and his son's friends and
he said when it got to the end of it
people too sat in the audience for ten
minutes and a guy ripped his shirt off
and started screaming why at the screen
and marching around the theater and he
thought all right I gotta get out of
here before somebody hurts me he snuck
out the side door we actually never
thought of it as a cliffhanger in our
own brains we were telling a complete
story this was Thanos's movie who's the
lead of the film and we gave him a
complete heart and here a proper ending